hi everybody and uh first of all I'd
like to just cover
a few things before we start we're going
to start with the cane
so in the can
this is footwork of Titans
in Wood cane you sometimes have a little
bit more turned in not a greater
difference but
yeah
I'll show you back Target sir
the closer
by turning this back foot in a bit more
watch this
it turns my hips over there Square
so
there's a tie dip so I'm a little more
open
this way to my ride in this case
and but turning in it brings the hips
more even more Square not quite
it's going to twist but more Square
and it will start like you know or you
say use the hips but we use the hips in
a tipping manner
in a pelvic tip so when we cast we do a
pelvic tip
we know the pelvic tip
however tip we don't turn
this way
we don't turn
that's right
so a lot of people get this confused
because when they think that they have
to cut
and perhaps hear that they've got the
candles and straight and when they come
down they're cutting forward and you
actually watch my hips my hips are
turning away from me and turning this
way so you get this
worship
okay and this is
two
planes
going
in two different directions
so two planes going in
two different directions so your hips
are going stuck on a flat line
and your cup is going outwards on a
straight
plan
if you take the Ken from the Sun and you
always take the blade facing towards you
you take it evenly within the spice and
if somebody hands it to you so I'm going
to pretend to be by the people so I'm
going to give my case somebody I take it
so I'm now the receiver I put my hands
in the middle of there too
and to stay alive I roll it towards me
okay I'm all the blade towards me so
there they've got
they've got the blade
facing towards them
the hands are open
you know
tape in between the hands with the hands
slightly relax
and
they roll it
and better
foreign
just a quick lift and about
and as I was saying in the first film
there's no respect in that so you should
raise it politely
and about
please note this that I don't put my
butt out
okay
it's not this
please be observed of other people
teachers high levels it doesn't matter
what what level they are you have a
power of eyes whatever land you are and
therefore you can teach yourself so so
when you're taking with the sword
so you've got the sword you've walked
from the edge of the mat you've taken
your thought
come to the Showman
you've offered it to the showroom with
the blade facing you a new a new bow
without moving the butt
so in my case
I walk into the dojo
because I understand safe I'm going to
go to my cabin Joe
I pick it up so don't pick it up I roll
it
if you like you could say that these two
points are the hands
I'm the receiver so I'm going in between
the arms
I take and I roll it immediately
I make characters it's a short distance
like this under the camera
I offer it widen my arms
and I and I bow
position
please bow very privately
it's an as you've had high principles
you keep this attitude throughout your
whole training it will always become a
good martial artist
thank you for your time please don't be
casual with your weapons
we call it his own machine awareness is
there from the moment you walk in the
dojo
to the moment you leave it and then try
to carry that exam shoulders out
throughout your life out there in
general public
thank you for your time